but like how how far have you guys gone
with like your morbid curiosities right
because the internet is a wonderful but
sometimes a terrifying place where you
can see anything you want to see yes
right um and i know a lot of people a
lot of kids went through a phase where
they they stumbled upon like the darker
side of the internet right like you know
because i'm not even gonna pretend to
sugarcoat the fact that like yeah you
know at one point when i was in high
school someone was like do you know of
this thing called tor and i was like no
what's that and so i downloaded it and i
was like oh it's a gateway to the dark
web
and you know i spent an afternoon one
afternoon on tour you know going through
the dark web just to see how [ __ ] up
it was and uh can confirm that's a
[ __ ] up [ __ ] on there yeah cause like
for me like i like i didn't do anything
like no no no
i didn't enjoy it joey incriminates
himself i didn't do anything i just i
saw a lot of things that i probably
shouldn't have seen right yeah like like
even to me like my baseline i could not
go on like if i see a lively thing i'm
clicking off that video no i just i just
like i've never had that kind of part of
myself where i was morbidly curious
enough to see something that i probably
would regret i can live the rest of my
life not seeing this i've seen the worst
things on twitter yeah yeah that's i'll
be honest
with you the most [ __ ] up videos i've
ever seen have been on twitter actually
that's true some
really [ __ ] up things and i'm i
thought you were just like being
facetious there i thought i thought
i thought you were just like oh i had
this tweet i saw the other day like
friends like like people who i i
followed and i knew they'd like retweet
and be like oh this is horrible it's a
video of like some people getting shot
and stuff yeah yeah yeah i've seen that
[ __ ] why are you sharing this i've i've
actually seen that as well i thought you
would be positioned to be like i saw
this tweet the other day that said that
demons better than justice
oh my god horrendous
he actually thought you were talking
about
this
okay i you know i've i i i know exactly
the pre-2010 era of the internet yeah
everyone loves sharing [ __ ] up [ __ ]
yeah
we're
haunting stuff being shared on twitter
yeah yeah twitter is very slow to get
rid of this stuff yeah yeah it's nearly
as good as other platforms
and uh yeah all the [ __ ] [ __ ] there
man i yeah yeah some of it's still
burned into yeah yeah i've never been on
that i've never been on the dark web i
don't really have an interest i
don't weirdly enough like
the stuff i saw on the dark web just
like just based on like what you see as
an image or whatever is not as [ __ ] up
as some of the stuff you'd see on like
reddit
i'm just kidding
no one talks about kidding yeah
no it's just like i think it's just like
i think the thing that's like [ __ ] up
about the dark web from my experience on
going on it is just like there's
conceptually a lot of [ __ ] up things
yeah like when you read into it it's
like oh how about you people buying
drugs
that's like ninety percent that's like
the people selling
you know there's
but like you know there's like a lot of
other stuff you'd look into and it's
like oh where it's like okay i probably
didn't want to know that that was an
operation that is currently functioning
right now it's somewhere out there in
the world you know levels are [ __ ] up
whereas like you go live link in twitter
it's like you're immediately exposed to
something that's like oh that's oh i
shouldn't have seen like i didn't want
to see a guy's head explode on live leak
but i just did yeah well it's just like
there's one of the few times that a
video like that or a picture has like
like gone through the cracks you know
it's just like it's never not been
haunting for me in like every way shape
from like i remember every [ __ ]
[ __ ] up thing i see because i see it
once and i'm just like that is now like
[ __ ] ingrained in my mind and that
would be a point where i'm in the shower
i have like a [ __ ] flashback to that
video i'm like my day is just infinitely
worse and i'm just like
but there's a part of me there where
like i know this is reality and i know
like the internet is filtered so yeah it
is more friendly but like there's a part
of me where i'm just like i don't want
to be desensitized to this thing you
know because i know i've met some people
who are just like you think that's baby
[ __ ] i've seen the real [ __ ] i've seen
the [ __ ] up [ __ ] i've seen the snuff
film why and i'm just like well
to me like
i like being sensitive to this stuff
right because this [ __ ] is it grounds me
yeah this [ __ ] grounds you and like the
true crime stuff as well like to me at
least like to me i don't want to be too
desensitive to the group to the true
crime stuff in case
in case this happens in my real life and
i know someone that has that has
happened
that it happens to you i don't i don't
want to be desensitized to that in my
mind so let's be real like you know if
some person comes up to you and says
like oh well that's that's some [ __ ]
[ __ ] i've seen the more [ __ ] up stuff
i'm like that's not a brag
like why do you think you're cool
because you've seen like a bunch of live
league videos and you're not facebook i
want to leave yeah like that doesn't
make that's not gonna make me be like oh
my god what an absolute [ __ ] mega
chat this guy is for like sitting
through a bunch of lively playlists it's
like no that just makes me not want to
be near you because you're [ __ ] weird
is it lovely shut down now yes
i believe it has really since when
i
what a good thing damn missed out i'm
scared
so much good content lost forever yeah
no it's horrible but yeah i don't know
it's just like because there was you
know especially during like the the peak
of like reddit 5050 right yeah like the
mid-2010s remember when that was the
question i explained what we read at
50-50 i i don't i kind of don't want it
because i don't want people going on to
it is this still a thing i don't know
i think it's salty but red of 5050 is
basically it's this subreddit where
people post this like link uh where it's
like it's like you have a 50 50 chance
when you click the link of it's a really
nice thing or it's a really bad thing
and when i say nice and bad i mean like
really nice and like the worst
nsfl [ __ ] you will ever see like
straight from lively so there's you know
an example would be like
uh write a 50 50. uh five cute puppies
or five decapitated heads
and you won't know which one it is until
you click the link yeah yeah and uh in
the 2010s that was a game people like
kids used to play you know like i
remember some of my [ __ ] high school
friends were like you know in a skype
call back in the day was like you wanna
do a little bit of read a 50 50. as if
they're inviting me to like a minecraft
server you know it's like it's like yeah
yeah that's just casual gaming you know
and uh you know poor naive me the first
time around uh i was like no what's
reddit 50 50. biggest mistake in my life
i did that for five minutes i was like i
don't wanna i don't wanna i don't wanna
talk to you guys ever again for letting
me sit through that because i was
horrible
and uh yeah and then it became a big
thing on [ __ ] youtube yeah which is
why i feel sorry for like like the one
of the worst jobs i could imagine is the
people who work for moderate rate of
feedings
nice [ __ ] stuff
like one of these people who had been
interviewed yeah they had to like go
through yeah job seems like the worst
job on earth it's just like completely
desensitized like just hearing them talk
they're just like apparently obviously
you'd have to like go through a bunch of
uh really horrific views and
really uh [ __ ] up really right
opinions yeah i think yeah apparently
like a lot of them would like get really
desensitized and become like really
[ __ ] up the more they do this job i
think i think it was that vice
documentary where like the girl said
that like oh yeah once you apply for
this position you just like immediately
like get therapy yeah like it just comes
with the package it comes with the
package yeah that there is a therapist
yeah
like maybe on slime maybe online but
terrifying thought i know there's a job
out there that immediately requires you
to have therapy yeah but kind of like
you they need the like they're they're
the [ __ ] real heroes oh yeah there
needs to be someone out there that makes
the [ __ ] internet safer for people
like us that don't want to see that on
our timeline otherwise you know what's
the difference between the normal web
and the dark web at that point right
like yeah yeah yeah exactly just exactly
the same thing exactly right i just hope
they're getting treated [ __ ] fairly
and treated well and getting paid well i
hope that's a [ __ ] horrible job i
hope they get the best [ __ ] therapist
if they don't have the best [ __ ]
therapists on the planet like jesus
christ it's not worth